lots of stuff coming out of President
Trump's face yeah lots of stuff and most
of it isn't very good plus some staffing
chaos over a toy house we'll talk about
all of these things and more I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
so if you sense him unwi in me if he
sends a little bit of tiredness that's
because I was up at 2 o'clock Pacific
time so I could fly back and do the show
but never fear we shall soldier through
because I mean that's just the kind of
people we are through rain through sleet
through snow through hail we must not
let the Shapiro show fail so we will do
all of the coverage in just a second and
many a piece of news there B so we'll
get through all of those things first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Skillshare so yeah you are
trying to make a living to yourself and
more than that you're trying to increase
your living you're trying to make a
better wage you're trying to some for
that better job you're trying to start a
side business well that's where
Skillshare comes in it's an online
learning platform with over 18,000
classes and design business technology
and more sits class and graphic design
social media marketing illustration
mobile photography people around here
they're taking these classes all the
time because they don't take the classes
and make their skillset better they get
fired so it's good that they're taking
classes over at Skillshare it's also
good thing for you to take classes over
at Skillshare because now you have a
whole set of skills you can put down on
your resume and all of these classes are
taught by experts they're 45 minutes
long they're really top-notch they are
really good they really work I've used a
couple of them took one on SEO marketing
also took one on watercolours which
helps me relax after I'm done fomenting
rebellion in this show join the millions
of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners get two months of
Skillshare for just 99 cents so they're
offering my listeners right now two
months of unlimited access to over
18,000 classes for just 99 cents so you
go to skill shared comm slash Shapiro
for that deal Skillshare comm slash
Shapiro again when you use slash Shapiro
you get two months for just 99 cents of
unlimited access you can check it out
see whether you like it I promise you
will it's fantastic Skillshare comm
slash prepare to get your two months for
99 cents Skillshare comm slash appear
I'll also use slash apparel so they know
that we sent you alright so yesterday
the President of the United States
decided that he was going to hold
another one of these open meetings with
Democrats and Republicans in front of
the cameras now usually in front of the
cameras the president tries to please
members of both parties the president
above all is a performer crazy guy who's
on reality TV he's been on the cover of
every magazine he's been performing
he's been performing every single you
know all the time for years
and that performance does not stop just
because he's the President of the United
States when a camera is on when the red
light is on he's performing and what
that usually means that he's trying to
cater to the people in the room so when
he's performing at CPAC and the red
lights are on there he's saying what
CPAC wants to hear and when he's in
front of the NRA then he is saying what
the NRA wants to hear and when he is in
front of a bunch of Democrats and
Republicans he's saying well he thinks a
lot of the Democrats would want to hear
and that's basically how went yesterday
now we're gonna analyze the Sun two
levels one is did he mean any of this is
it real and two is what did he just say
because we sort of always have to
separate out these two things what he
said and is it important these are two
separate questions because the president
says a lot of stuff a lot of crap comes
out of that face so the question is was
the stuff that he said good or was it
bad and - was it important well that's
for the second question first I don't
think the stuff that he said was
important he's gonna have to get the
legislation through Congress Republicans
run Congress they're not gonna do any of
the things that he wants them to do here
because they don't have the votes for it
the reason I say this is because the
president did exactly the same thing
with daca
you recall that he had a meeting with a
bunch of Democrats and at that meeting
on daca he specifically said that he
would be fine with passing a clean daca
bill we mocked him up and down for it it
was ridiculous he said that he was fine
with a clean amnesty bill and no border
security measures and Kevin McCarthy the
House Majority Leader had jump in and
say mr. president you mean they want
border security and Trump's against her
I mean I mean I want a clean bill with
border security which is not originally
what he said now of course all of his
overtures to Democrats in that meeting
meant nothing the same thing is probably
happening here on guns but it is
important to note the president only
became an advocate of gun rights
relatively recently up till 2012 the
president was a gun control advocate the
president was not a big fan of guns and
so when it goes back to the root the gut
level for President Trump when he goes
back to his gut on this issue there are
certain issues where the president's gut
is very much in line with with sort of
conservative policy guns are not one of
those issues on guns this is a guy whose
gut is from New York and New Yorkers
people from New York City they're not
particularly big into the second
Amendment rights of all of it so the
president has this meeting yesterday and
he says a bunch of things that are just
laughably awful so he starts off by in a
conversation with Pat Toomey so Pat
Toomey is the is the senator from
Pennsylvania now in order for you to
understand how absurd it is what
President Trump says right here you have
to understand that Pat Toomey is one of
the
left most members of the US Senate on
guns so in 2013 it was it was Pat Toomey
who proposed a piece of legislation in
the aftermath of Sandy Hook with Senator
Joe Manchin from West Virginia Democrat
and that piece of legislation would have
forced federal background checks for any
sale of any weapon in the United States
except between family members or close
friends so if I wanted to sell a gun to
somebody in the office with whom I was
not friendly then I would have to go to
a federally licensed firearms dealer now
the only way to enforce that the problem
this policy is the only way to enforce
that law is that you actually have to
have a full gun registry because in
order for the government's keep track of
how I sold my gun to somebody they have
to know that I own the gun in the first
place right a federally licensed
firearms dealer keeps records with the
federal government they know how many
guns are in that gun shop and so when
that love firearms dealer is requested
for records by the NRA rather thee by
the ATF then the ATF knows that where
the guns were how they were transported
all the rest of it that would have set
up a gun registry in the United States
gun registries are really troubling
concept you really don't want the
government knowing who has a gun and
where because it's none of the
government's business there are two
purposes to the Second Amendment one is
self-defense in which case you don't
really care about the government knowing
you have a gun and the second is being
free of government tyranny and in that
case you really don't want the
government to know who has how many guns
and where and obviously there's a
certain amount of of knowledge the
government has with regard to federally
licensed firearms dealers but having a
full gun registry is not quite the same
thing as all that the government would
have to come into your house and check
every so often the government would have
to figure out whether you were telling
the truth the government could
theoretically charge you with perjury
for lying on federal forms if you if you
did not fill out the forms properly and
these hand hand transfers in any case
the manchin-toomey bill went down to
defeat it got 54 votes in the Senate it
could not hit 60 but to me who had
proposed it was bucking the NRA when he
proposed that so to me actually his NRA
rating was demoted from an A to a C and
it was demoted from an agency not only
was it demoted from an A to a C in 2014
the NRA declined to endorse to me so
they'd endorsed to me in his last
senatorial race and then they unendorsed
to me in 2008 so that's how seriously
they honor I took all of this and that's
how much at odds to me was with the NRA
well Trump because he always wants to be
the guy saying the brashest thing in the
room he starts ripping into to me for
some reason and suggesting the to me is
a tool of the
our a which is just idiotic it doesn't
make sense said I have to wait till I'm
21 to get a handgun but I can get this
weapon at 18 I don't know so I just
curious as to what you did in your bill
look at all the staffers even Manchin is
going he's not afraid of the NRA he and
I partnered on the legislation what the
hell are you talking about the Trump is
accusing to me being afraid of the NRA
which is just great press for the NRA
considering the entire Democratic Party
and the media have been claiming that
the real reason Republicans are pro-gun
is because they're afraid of the NRA so
well done mr. president for doubling
down on that idiotic message then the
president went even further and that's
the clip we're about to show you where
where Dianne Feinstein jumps for joy Amy
Klobuchar who's the senator from
Minnesota
she suggests that they add an assault
weapons ban to manchin-toomey so not
only would there be a full gun registry
now you would not be able to buy an
assault weapon meaning any rifle in the
United States that has a couple of
features added to it like a pistol grip
and and a certain type of barrel for
example if he or a sight if he added
those things if the government looks
scary it's an assault weapon Republicans
have opposed this forever
Amy Klobuchar says why don't we do it
and Trump immediately says yeah let's
wrap that up into an even bigger gun
control package and watch Dianne
Feinstein's reaction Dianne Feinstein is
84 years old but suddenly she's a little
girl again Dianne Feinstein she's been
my senator virtually my entire life
she's been senator here since I was 10
years old Dianne Feinstein her 9 years
old I have never seen Dianne Feinstein
smile ever not once on tape like it
needs it there's there's this myth that
once Dianne Feinstein smiled and a
rainbow came out like she's not a big
laugher and a big smile er hey watch as
she turns into a small child clapping
for Glee like my kids when I give them
chocolate when Trump says this about
assault weapons it's really amazing just
doing something on this background check
issue and using that as a base and then
I would like to add some of these other
things we've talked about I think would
make a major difference you can add that
to this bill that would be great
you have also and I think you can into
the bill so were you ready can you do
them Joe can you do them better make
some of the things you're not you don't
really have you help well no I'll help
but can you add what Amy and what Dianne
have K we had the minute and I know you
can add what you okay and look at the
Republicans are like what is going on
now
like Cornyn who's sitting right next to
trump he's putting his hand to his mouth
like this can't be happening this isn't
real like Trump really doesn't know it
he's saying here and Dianne Feinstein
knows exactly our Trump saying again
she's 84 years old
and suddenly she's my four-year-old
daughter she's so gleeful if you are
saying things about guns that are making
Dianne Feinstein gleeful let me suggest
that you've undermined the Second
Amendment and that you are not standing
with conservative ideas on the Second
Amendment okay then it gets you more so
he turned us to corn and who's sitting
right next to him he says you know we
should do we should actually do a
comprehensive gun reform like a big big
bill like a big historic bill and you
can see Cornyn going what the hell is
going on like was he dropped on his head
this morning did he did he wake up on
the wrong side of the bed was invasion
of the body snatchers like what in the
world look at look at John Cornyn space
here and John fix Nick's has some really
good things in it but it would be nice
if we could add everything on to it and
maybe you changed the title alright the
US background check bill or whatever but
your bill is really good and really
important having to do with a certain
aspect but maybe we could make it much
more comprehensive and have one bill
instead of 15 different bills that
nobody knows what's happening if we can
get 60 votes for mr. Pradhan steps in he
goes according to steps and he goes mr.
president your acting coach I old we
need 60 votes and we're not gonna get it
so the president of course just
completely overlooks this it was just
ridiculous ridiculous on every possible
level and and it gets even more
ridiculous okay so this is the thing
that is most ridiculous and had people
really up in arms as they should be so
the president is talking about a vice
president pence starts talking about a
proposal those first made by David
French a proposal that I back forgotten
violence restraining orders gun violence
restraining orders our process that we
have here in California where close
family and friends can apply to a court
to have your gun rights temporarily
suspended if they show past a certain
burden of proof that there is evidence
that you are danger to yourself or
and then there is a hearing right so
there's due process so the due process
can go in a couple ways you can have the
hearing before the guns are removed or
you could have a preliminary hearing in
which all of the evidence is shown and
then the guns are temporarily removed
because we don't want people sitting
around there with guns and then the guns
are and then the guy realizes that the
cops are going to come take away his
guns go shoots up to school okay so the
you can have due process in the sense
that you have the right to confront the
accuser but it's done on really
spontaneous quick basis or you could
have like a full drawn-out hearing but
both of those are due process so Mike
Pence explains the proposal and Trump
proceeds to piledrive the proposal Trump
proceeds to take Pence's proposal the
gun violence restraining order proposal
the David French proposal and he
proceeds to say something so wildly
unconstitutional and so wildly
unconservative
that it boggles the mind I mean if
Barack Obama had uttered these words we
would all be up in arms the reason that
it's different if Obama had sent them
and then Trump sang them honestly is
that Obama knew what he was talking
about on these issues and Trump clearly
doesn't anyway here is here's Mike Pence
saying something smart and then Donald
Trump following up with something so
egregiously stupid that minds of small
children were blown all over the country
because a lot of times by the time you
go to court it takes so long to go to
court to get the due process procedures
I like taking the guns early like in
this crazy man's case it just took place
in Florida he had a lot of fires they
saw everything to go the court would
have taken a long time so you could do
exactly what you're saying but take the
guns first go through due process second
okay that's not what due process is the
reason this is a problem is not because
anybody wants mentally ill violent
people to have guns nobody wants that
but it is astonishing to me that the
same people on the Left who are afraid
of Trump becoming an authority Rhian are
sitting there laughing with glee when
the President of the United States says
somebody applies to have somebody else's
gun rights taken away and we should all
just shrug
I mean honestly that's what the
President of the United States says
right there the presidents in the United
States just said that you should be able
to go into the police should be able to
go into your house I should be able to
go to the cops and say to them my
next-door neighbor is crazy
and that's your idea of it it's right
there's no due process I just call up
and I say tip next door neighbor is
crazy in the gun and the cops go and
take that guy's guns and maybe arrest
him right and then later comes the due
process we fought an entire revolution
to prohibit this sort of thing we fought
in
revolutions that there will be a right
to habeas corpus so you know why you're
being arrested and your rights are being
violated we we fought an entire
revolution so their ex post facto laws
laws that were specifically designed
after the fact in order to get certain
people none of this is part of the
constitutional order but the president
who's a Republican was sitting there
saying this stuff with a straight face
now this brings us to our to our I'll
get to the last question as to whether
any of this is important in a second he
didn't even stop there is I mean
everybody on the right is just looking
at this going what happened I mean what
it was every WTF gift that you can find
online was it with my I mean every face
that you can make right the was just was
being made by Republicans yesterday
watching this thing unfold in real time
it's astonishing it's astonishing okay
then he goes he says he goes after Steve
Scalise Steve Scalise shooting victim in
the Congressional baseball shooting Ben
Scalise has proposed in the NRA is
proposed in Trump has endorsed in his
2016 election cycle the idea of carrot
concealed carry reciprocity concealed
carry reciprocity is the idea that when
you apply for a concealed carry license
in Oklahoma and you are approved by the
government for that concealed carry
license you should be able to concealed
carry and other any other state normally
this sort of thing is fine like we have
a marriage license in one state it's
usually transferable over to another
state if you have if you have a liquor
license in one state and it fulfills the
obligations of the other state then it
should be able to be fulfilled in that
state I believe but when it comes to
concealed carry there's questions as to
whether you should be able to take your
concealed carry license from Oklahoma
and bring it over to California and and
so Trump is told by Steve Scalise that
they want this concealed carry
reciprocity and president Trump's
response is as always amazing here's the
President of the United States
responding to Steve Scalise by saying
it's utterly it's it we can never do
this it can't be a thing and there were
a lot of our members that said look we
want to close these these problems and
fix these problems with the background
check system and we came together and
actually passed a bill but we also felt
that if you look at the concealed carry
population these are people by and large
who are helping us stop crimes these are
people who are well trained who actually
go out there and help prevent crimes
some would hope that that's not
immediately dismiss because there is a
lot of talk of just putting that on the
side and just like you think this you
know I'm your biggest fan of them
alright I think that maybe that bill
will someday pass but it should pass as
a separate if you're gonna put concealed
carry between states into this bill
we're talking about a whole new ballgame
look at clobber char look at her okay
the senator from Minnesota look at the
Democrat she's sitting there nodding
along and the Republicans are all
sitting there at their arms crossed look
at the body language here all the
Republicans are going where is this
coming from this is the guy who days ago
was talking about how great the NRA was
this is a guy who was a few days ago
talking about the value of gun rights
this is a guy who a couple of days ago
was talking about how we needed to
protect our right to keep him bear arms
and it does shed some light on something
the president said during his CPAC
speech during that CPAC speech he had
this very weird line where he said if
you could choose between tax cuts and
gun rights which would you choose and he
was expecting everybody in the room to
say tax cuts and everybody in the rooms
had gun rights and he was kind of
shocked by it he's again the president
is not a stalwart on gun rights and on a
gut level he's not now one of the nice
things is that the President of the
United States can be turned to whoever
talks to him last this is one of the
nice things about the president he's
willing to hear opposing points of view
is the nice way of putting it also the
President of the United States can't do
all these things because he just doesn't
have the votes but here is where it does
become important so this stuff is not
important right now because when Trump
says stuff right now
who cares Paul Ryan Mitch McConnell
they're the ones who are putting the
legislation together when he said dumb
stuff about Obama care it didn't really
matter very much when he said dumb
things about the tax bill it didn't
things about immigration it didn't
matter very much the president saying
dumb things is baked into the cake we
all know that the president is gonna say
stuff and we're all gonna go war and
we've all gotten used to that but what
happens if in November Democrats take
back the House of Representatives and
let's say they get really lucky and they
take back the Senate let's say the
Democrats suddenly have controlled the
Senate and the House of Representatives
then all of a sudden the President of
the United States saying these things
may actually make a difference because
you could see a situation in which
Democrats are the ones writing the bill
right now the check on the president
saying dumb things is a Congress that's
not going to write dumb things but what
happens when the Congress can write some
things what happens when Nancy Pelosi is
Speaker of the House and she's sitting
in a meeting like this with the
President of the United States and he
says I want you to put XY and Z into a
bill once a comprehend
gun reform bill that's going to require
full background checks for every sale in
the United States which would require
registry and everything that the
president has about assault weapons
who'd be wrapped into a bill and no
concealed carry reciprocity and raising
the age to buy rifle and the president
says all this in front of Nancy Pelosi
and she says sure mr. president well
with you and what happens when Chuck
Schumer is the Senate Majority Leader
and he says to Trump sounds great mr.
president I'll tell you what happens the
president gets all of the bad things we
don't want him to be saying and having
right now that's what happens how do I
know that's what happens because that's
exactly what happened on the budget last
year you recall that Mitch McConnell and
Paul Ryan were using the debt ceiling
debate as a way to cut some spending and
the President of the United States had
in Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer and he
said to them directly listen guys I
don't care about cutting anything let's
just blow out the spending and they said
fine and they walked out and Paul Ryan
Mitch McConnell were just stunned
because the President did have the
capacity to do that he had the votes to
do that well right now it doesn't matter
again because the Republicans are
running the show but when the
Republicans are not running the show
things are going to get pretty dicey
pretty quickly which is why it's
important that Republicans maintain
control of the house as a check on
president Trump because the president's
instincts are not always good on these
sorts of things and he's not surrounded
by a bunch of Second Amendment advocates
can the people who are closest to the
president aside from Mike Pence these
are not all SuperPro Second Amendment
people it's it's a serious issue and
nobody is checking him on the areas
where he does have control so another
area where he has control and where he's
saying dumb things is the area of trade
so today the president tweeted this out
this is 17 the president tweeted this
out about trade they tweeted quote our
steel and aluminum industries and many
others have been decimated by decades of
unfair trade and bad policy with
countries from around the world we must
not let our country companies and
workers be taken advantage of any longer
we want free fair and smart trade so
Charlie cook over at National Review had
a great point about this last sentence
Norton says we want free fair and smart
trade and he says if you use the words
free fair and smart about for example
speech if you said we want free fair and
smart speech you'd realize that this is
a violation of free speech principles
right fair speech and smart speech are
not requisites you just need free speech
when it comes to trade the same thing is
true the notion of fair trade is a is is
something chimerical it's
the reason I say it's silly is because
comparative advantages since since the
days of Ricardo has suggested that you
are an idiot
if you heighten tariffs on your own just
because the other guy has heightened
tariffs on you as I'm constantly saying
just be let's say that you are in the
business of building shelves at the
local grocery store and they stop using
you right they've they've essentially
set up a tariff on you they don't use
you anymore
do you stop shopping at that grocery
store if they have the lowest prices
only if you want to get poor or do you
do that okay so but the president
doesn't understand how trade works the
president thinks that trade is not
reciprocal the president thinks that all
of these industries have been quote
unquote estimated so today the president
had a meeting with all of these steel
and aluminum industry leaders and he
said that he was going to raise tariffs
dramatically on steel and aluminum he
apparently said that he wants to raise
the steel tariffs by 25% he wants to
slap a stain over all steel tariffs of
25% on foreign steel and a 10% aluminium
tariffs on aluminum disaster area
full-scale disaster area the reason this
is a full-scale disaster area is because
these are inputs for other industries in
the United States for every job in the
steel industry there are 40 jobs and
other industries that use steel which
means that if you're in the car industry
and you use steel and suddenly the price
of steel goes up because of these
tariffs and they have to sell your car
more expensively and it is less
competitive in the global market unless
you tear off cars and then if you tear
off cars then you're going to have to
increase the price on cars and people to
spend money their tariffs are a terrible
economic policy they've always been a
terrible economic policy for every job
that is saved by steel by by these by
these tariffs other jobs are lost when
the bush tariffs on steel went into
effect from 2001 to 2004 is about 21
months and when those tariffs were in
effect the United States lost
approximately 200,000 jobs by studies
and not only that the economy suffered
overall because of that according to
estimates every single steel job created
by a tariff American consumers paid an
additional 200,000 to 2.3 million
dollars that's how much it cost to
preserve a steel job and that's what's
happening here
remember there are industries in the
United States like the beer industry
uses aluminum to make its cans
anheuser-busch came out today they said
this is
idiotic you just raised the price of
beer on everybody who wants to buy an
Heiser Busch beer you gonna buy a miller
lite well now you're going to be paying
a higher price for that watered-down
beer and this is not good policy it's
also it's just ignorant I mean when he
says that the steel and aluminum
industries in the United States are
gonna have been decimated by decades of
unfair trade it's not true it's just not
factually true in 2016 the steel
industry actually did really well thanks
for dramatically increased car sales
Nucor is the nation's leading steel
manufacturer it's 16 billion dollars in
sales that year last year it's netting
her earnings increased 65 percent over
2016 the average salaried that company
by the way is $80,000 most job loss at
new core has happened thanks to
technological advances not thanks to
foreign trade right now 70% of all steel
sold in the United States is American
steel as for the argument that we need
steel tariffs in order to protect the
capacity of our military to have steel
to use for its weaponry that's like
three percent of all the steel
production in the United States would
have to be used for a full-scale
military mobilization in the United
States it's just not true either
methylates not just nuke or which their
stock price in 2000 was 12 bucks today
at $65 so obvious they're not doing that
badly
US Steel boomed in 2017 in q4 of 2016
net earnings were forty-seven million
dollars but by q4 of 2017 net earnings
were 136 million dollars they had a
massive boom last year steel dynamics
showed an operating income of 1.1
billion dollars last year as for
America's production of raw steel we're
producing about the same amount of raw
steel that we were producing in 1980 has
been pretty consistent for the last
three and a half decades almost four
decades cato institute trailer Scott
Lincecum points out again the u.s. steel
production rose 5% last year there are
already a hundred and sixty duties on
steel imports and if you think this is
just a way to screw China because China
is dumping its cheap steel on us
nonsense
China ranks 11th in steel importation
into the United States
ok how about and again the most
important thing here is the number of
jobs this is gonna cost in another
industry the CFO of anheuser-busch said
this quote about 2 million jobs depend
on America's beer industry we urged the
Department of Commerce and US President
Trump to consider the impact of trade
restriction tariffs okay but he's not
gonna reconsider it because this is
something that he has power over and
right now he's feeling particularly
threatened the president
the United States right now President
Trump is feeling very isolated and that
means that he is bringing in his toys
and he's bringing his comfort food and
his teddy bears and his teddy bears on
issues like this is a guy named Peter
Navarro who wrote a book on trade that
makes no sense and is in a supremely
foolish and he is Trump's guru on trade
because Trump has always felt that
America is getting screwed because
Trump's vision of what American industry
is is guys who are working a blue-collar
job in downtown Manhattan building a
building with steel he's got a very 1955
version of what American industry looks
like that's not what American industry
looks like right now the job loss in the
steel industry has been brought about by
technological change and of course the
vast majority of jobs in this country
are no longer in manufacturing they're
in the service industry and when the
president says that I'm supposed to pay
more for a car to preserve that steel
job what he's really doing is penalizing
me for being in an industry that's more
efficient than the steel industry has
been on a global level we by the way are
still the number two producers of all
steel on planet earth but again this is
bad economics from the president the
president is just saying things except
this time he's actually gonna do it so
next week he's supposed to impose these
tariffs and the market is reacting just
exactly how you would think they were is
reacting right there's gonna be a big
trade war because not only is it going
to have a not only is it going to have a
significant impact on the steel industry
and and industries that are fed by steel
in the United States it's gonna have
impact on other industries because other
countries are going to raise their
tariffs on us in retaliation they
shouldn't but they will in an attempt to
back us down hey they're going to now
raise their own tariffs so today as of
this point the stock market has been
dropping pretty precipitously
it has tumbled 600 points over the
tariff talks so it finally stabilized
after a really bad month February was
crappy month for the stock market today
the gg the Dow Jones Industrial Average
is down 490 points to this point it's
taking a big dip let's have for took a
bunch of huge dips last month so well
done President Trump with just by you
announcing these tariffs you sunk the
stock market 500 points it won't end
there by the way there's still a lot of
doubt as to whether this actually gets
imposed cuz again Trump says so many
things but it is not true that yeah the
the President of the United States
saying these things does have an impact
if he ends up imposing them so this is
why I say I'm gun
I think people cut it and are cutting
him a lot of slack so they don't think
it's actually gonna happen but when it
comes to trade policy the President does
have the unilateral authority to raise
tariffs this way and this could be a
full-scale disaster for the economy it
could be a real disaster for a number of
industries especially if he decides that
he is gonna go to trade war with every
country that slaps tariffs on us because
you could see this escalating you can
see Trump saying we're gonna put the
steel tariffs the aluminum tariffs and
then you could see France saying to us
well they're gonna do that to us
we're gonna put tariffs on not just
steel and aluminum we're gonna put
tariffs on all your other goods too and
then Trump says well screw you I'll put
tariffs on arthas we're stronger than
you the zero-sum version of economics is
is just ignorant it doesn't make any
sense at all and it's very frustrating
to watch a Republican president do it
because it's very dumb now again one of
the reasons I think this is happening is
because the president obviously feels
isolated the president feels like a lot
of his a lot of his favorite people have
been marginalized in the last couple of
weeks so over the last week the Josh FL
who is the comms director for Jared
Kushner has been marginalized Kushner
himself has been marginalized a little
bit as I said by the by the revocation
of his interim top-secret security
status there's a story today in the New
York Times that's very damaging to
Kushner about his family business
receiving loans after he held meetings
with business people it's according to
the New York Times early last year a
private equity billionaire started
paying regular visits to the White House
Joshua Harris a founder of Apollo Global
Management was advising trump
administration officials on
infrastructure policy during that period
he met on multiple occasions with Jared
Kushner president Trump's son-in-law and
senior advisors among other things the
two men discussed a possible White House
job for Harris the job never
materialized but in November
Apollo went 184 million dollars to
cushion his family real estate firm
Kushner companies the loan was to
refinance the mortgage on a Chicago
skyscraper this is one of their bigger
deals it's triple the average size of
their property loan it's one of the
largest ones Kushner company received
last year and even larger loan came from
Citigroup which lent the firm and one of
his partners 325 million dollars to help
finance a group of office buildings in
Brooklyn that loan was made in spring of
2017 right after Kushner met in the
White House with Citi group's chief
executive Michael Corbitt according to
people briefed on the meeting the two
men talked about financial and trade
policy and did not discuss Kushner's
family business is one of the problems
with having people in
Whitehouse who are deeply connected to
their businesses still and it's one of
the reasons why seasons from security
clearance has not been granted at this
point is because of these business
connections and this is not good
hey this is not good if this were
happening under Hillary would not be
good it's happening under Trump and it's
not good it doesn't matter whether you
like the people who are talking about
personally it doesn't matter if you like
the policies that are espousing the
media obviously have an agenda which is
to knock Kushner off the hill right now
they want to see cast inside the Trump
administration but as they're holding
this but that's not something that
Kushner should have been doing if Trump
wanted him to have meetings with
Citigroup and financial leaders then
Kushner should have basically become
disassociated into in entirety from all
the cushion or companies that apparently
has not happened so Kushner has been
marginalized and now hope Hicks is gone
so hope Hicks was his comfort blanket
hope Hicks who started off as a runway
model who joined Trump in 2016 she was
part of Ivanka's team she was his top
aide and she's now 29 and one of the
best liked people in the White House
everybody I know in the White House who
knows the hope egg says that she's a
wonderful person well she was according
to CNN excoriated by the president
because a couple of days ago she went in
front of Congress and she was asked
whether she'd ever had to lie on behalf
of the president she said well she told
some white lies like about audience eyes
like crowd sighs and that apparently
ticked off Trump according to CNN and
supposedly Trump yelled at her and then
hope Hicks quit that's the CNN story now
the New York Times says that she's been
preparing for weeks to leave
that's not a giant shock people in the
White House are routinely talking about
leaving because a very chaotic place
very high-stress job there's a lot of
turnover at any White House but
particularly in a White House that's run
from the top this way so hope it's
leaving I have some impact on the
administration I'll explain what impact
it has and what it means for Trump in
just a second but you're gonna have to
go over to Daley wired and subscribe for
the rest of it so for $9.99 a month you
can get your subscription to The Daily
wire that means you get the rest of this
show live the Andrew Klavan shall live
the Michael Mol's show live you get to
be part of my mailbag which is happening
tomorrow's and now is a great day to
subscribe so you can ask all the
questions that your little heart desires
and make your life that much better also
if you own the annual subscription
finally here in my hands I have it the
greatest tumbler in the history of
mankind and back in LA and I can feel
the warmth and the energy surging
through me as I hold this the best
beverage vest of all so you can hold it
too you can get
it's just like the skin of mine this is
mine you can have your own 499 dollars a
year when you get the annual
subscription or if you just want to
listen later go over to iTunes
SoundCloud YouTube please go over there
and subscribe please leave us a review
it always helps us we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
so as I say hope Hicks is sort of and
pushed to the side Jared right now is
being pushed to the side apparently
according to reports by General John
Kelly the chief of staff which means
that Kelly is the guy who's sort of
bringing people into the center of the
room and that means that Trump is more
likely to reach out to other people that
he wants to talk to if he feels like
Kelly is shutting him off from Jared
Kushner and that hope Hicks is gonna
leave then he's gonna start reaching out
to other people he's comfortable with
when one of the people he likes a lot
apparently is Peter Navarro Peter
Navarro this trade guy and it's not a
coincidence that while all this cast is
taking place
Peter Navarro is suddenly making
appearances in the Oval Office and Trump
is hanging out with him people that
Trump feels personally comfortable with
are the people he's gonna want to talk
to and unfortunately a lot of those
people have pretty bad ideas because
personal comfort should not be the gauge
of whether somebody's policy is good but
the president doesn't know a lot about
policy and he's very susceptible to
being told things by people that he
likes so Hicks being out has more of a
personal impact on Trump than it does a
policy impact but she is known as sort
of the person she sort of the Trump
whisper she's the person who can who can
handle Trump and has been able to to hem
him in a little bit make him feel better
about his presidency make him feel
better about things her being gone is
not going to be a good thing again Josh
raffle I think Spencer thaw is a press
aide whose initial portfolio is
primarily focused on Kushner and Ivanka
and he apparently is leaving also and
apparently Adina Powell
is left left a few weeks ago so high
turnover at the White House that means a
lot of pee a lot of faces Trump doesn't
recognize as he gets more uncomfortable
he's gonna look for friends and friends
around him are going to define what he
does which is sort of an uncomfortable
place
he's meanwhile busily attacking his own
Attorney General so yesterday the
president went on Twitter and he
attacked Attorney General Jeff Sessions
generally this this I've always found
really frustrating Attorney General
sessions I've met him a few times when
he was Senator sessions I think that
senator sessions is a is a rock solid
red state Republican I disagree with him
on trade I disagree with him in certain
areas of immigration but he was the very
first guy to endorse Trump I mean the
first major voice to endorse Trump very
very early in the campaign a real Trump
loyalist and as a G Trump has just
beaten the crap out of him publicly so
this is really in bad taste the one
thing that one of the things I like
about about sessions and that sessions
does have a strong sense of what he's
supposed to do as the Attorney General
that his job is not to just be the
wingman for the president now Trump
doesn't like that because he looks at
the Obama administration and he says
Eric Holder was Obama's wingman why
can't you be my wingman and the answer
is because the AG is not supposed to be
the president's wingman the AG is
supposed to administer the law Jeff
Sessions actually takes that rather
seriously so one of the areas where this
has happened is that Jeff Sessions asked
the inspector general to investigate
potential FISA abuse there's been a lot
of talk about FISA abusive they're
supposed abuse by the FBI and the DOJ a
DOJ of the FISA warrant process in the
attempt to get a warrant on Carter page
that former Trump campaign aide that
form a trump foreign policy aide and
sessions have listen I don't want the
GAO J investigating itself I don't want
the DOJ investigating the FBI let's set
somebody else he's independent because
here's the thing if I Attorney General
Jeff Sessions come down with the
conclusion that the Obama DOJ and the
Obama FBI went ahead and invaded the
campaign people are gonna note a couple
of things one I was a member of the
campaign too I was appointed by
President Trump and so they're not gonna
take it seriously so we'll set up an IG
I have a conflict of interest Trump
doesn't appreciate that and he wants
Jeff Sessions to just do what he wants
me to do which i think is wrong mr.
Trump tweets out why is the AG Jeff
Sessions asking the Inspector General to
investigate potentially massive thighs
abuse will take forever has no
prosecutorial power and already late
with reports on Comey etc isn't the IG
and Obama guy why not use Justice
Department lawyers all caps disgraceful
you know what's disgraceful is the
President of the United States berating
his own Attorney General publicly I
assume he has Jeff Sessions phone number
what does he think is gonna happen here
is he thinks sessions is gonna quit if
you just humiliates him enough I mean
the sessions knows Trump isn't gonna
fire him because Trump's been
threatening to fire him for over a year
he's not going anywhere
so he'll just sit it out he'll sit tight
he'll feel protect the law good four
sessions for doing that so there's no
purpose here other than Trump venting
and then mobilizing his allies to vented
sessions but maybe that makes his base
feel good maybe it makes them feel like
it's the it's the Geo J's fault that we
haven't seen any prosecutions but again
this is this is just not being not only
not presidential it's not effective
attacking your own Attorney General's
just bad policy so in a rarity sessions
actually fired back so you actually
issued a statement
ripping Trump
good for him he said we have initiated
the appropriate process that will ensure
complaints against this department will
be fully and fairly acted upon if
necessary as long as I'm the Attorney
General I will continue to discharge my
duties with integrity and honor and this
department will continue to do its work
in a fair and impartial manner according
to the law and the Constitution I'm good
for Jeff Sessions that's his job that's
exactly what he should be doing so it's
it's an absurdity that the president is
attacking his own Attorney General so
very bad 48 hours for the president's
attacking his own Attorney General
dumping all over gun rights and then
talking about raising tariffs
dramatically that would have a serious
impact on the economic growth that he's
attempting to reach so very bad 48 hours
for the president and again I think this
is what the president looks like when
he's done more which is why you have to
have checks in the White House it's why
you have to have good people surrounding
him it's why you need a Republican
Congress if you had a Democratic
Congress and a bunch of advisers around
the president telling him to do the
popular thing with Democrats this
presidency could go sideways very
quickly so while there was talk last
week about the president being an
ideological leader of the conservative
movement that is not true the president
has governed like a conservative so far
but he's not an ideological leader he's
a vehicle for the conservative movement
that means that if the conservative
movement doesn't call him out if the
conservative movement doesn't provide a
check when he when he commits anti
conservative heresies then there is a
possibility that Trump moves
significantly to the left and again if
the Democrats were smart they would know
this if the Democrats had any brains at
all they would spend all day just
praising Trump it's what they would do
it's been every day all day talking
about how Trump is generous Trump is
kind Trump is wonderful maybe they'd be
like all of the characters in Manchurian
Candidate talking about Raymond Burr and
what a wonderful generous human being he
is and Trump would buy that because the
man doesn't anything this is the danger
of having someone in the Oval Office who
doesn't have an ideology so far it
hasn't hurt those checks and balances
have worked I only hope they continue to
work I'll praise them I'll praise the
president when they do work and when he
does the right thing the last 48 hours
has not been that time to do the right
thing now speaking of the radicalism of
the Democrats when you look at the
Democrats themselves they have
radicalized so if they were smart as I
say they'd be triangulating with Trump
there would be attempting to make
overtures to Trump they could probably
get half that argenta done with Trump if
they did that but they're radicalizing
pretty quickly so there are a bunch of
top Democrats who attended a Louis
Farrakhan speech Jake Tapper over at CNN
who I criticized pretty heavily last
week for what I thought was an agreed
the awful Town Hall and then I praise
this week for doing an interview with
the sheriff Scott Israel in parkland
Florida he he did a tweet storm
yesterday that I think is quite good
where he attacked Democrats attacking
who attended lose Farrakhan speech he
was an amazing thing that the mainstream
media think had utterly not worthy of
note that Louis Farrakhan an open
anti-semite and open racist then in
generalize piece of crap that this guy
is treated as a celebrity by so many
top-level Democrats including Democrats
in the Congressional Black Caucus here
are some clips of Louis Farrakhan
talking and there were Democrats at the
speech top-level Democrats at the speech
I don't what they put on me the
government is my enemy
[Music]
the powerful Jews top-level Democrats
have praised Louis Farrakhan they taking
pictures of Louis Farrakhan Barack Obama
took pictures of the Louis Farrakhan
there were two co-sponsors of the
women's March who are present at this
speech at this one right here okay and
Democrats apparently had nothing to say
about that they will be at the women's
March again the radicalism of the
Democrats there's a lot of talk about
the alt-right in the last election cycle
I think it was fully merited I was one
of the people doing the talking
the Democrats are equally radical when
it comes to Lewis Farrakhan they've a
blind spot for anti-semitism so long as
that anti-semitism is coming from parts
of the community that are not white so
here is Lewis Farrakhan doing more of
this just really discussing stuff white
folks are going down
and Satan is going down and Farrakhan by
God's grace has pulled a cover of betsy
panic Jude and I'm here to say your time
is up
your world is men's peg I mean he's just
he's one of the worst people on planet
Earth hey this is the guy who who keith
Ellison who could have been the head of
DNC was endorsed by Chuck Schumer to be
the head of the DNC he was a member of
the Nation of Islam he defended Louis
Farrakhan for years the Congressional
Black Caucus has defended Louis
Farrakhan hey the Democrats are so
radical that is home likely they would
have the brains to actually triangulate
with Trump but their radicalism is also
they're allowed to get away with it
there was a poll yesterday showed 57% of
Americans supposedly think Trump is a
racist it's like 20% of Republicans and
80 plus percent of Democrats okay how
many how many people think that Louis
Farrakhan is a racist and therefore the
people who associate with him are racist
the reason that people think that Trump
is racist is because of the associations
at the alt-right during the last
campaign and some of the comments that
he's made well if you're gonna hold the
standard that standard has to be held on
both sides I don't see a lot of people
in the media doing it good on Jake
Tapper for doing it okay time for a
quick thing I like and then a couple of
things that I hate so thing I like today
I'm in the middle of a book by Mikhail
Bulgakov a Bulgakov rather mikail Booga
cough was a it was a guy who lived in
the Soviet Union he died I believe in
1941 but he written a book in secret
that was essentially a parody of
Stalin's Russia it was recommended to me
actually by Jordan Peterson and it's
quite an interesting book I'm about
halfway through it but it is it is a
funny book basically the concept is that
you are in Stalin's Russia and suddenly
Satan shows up and starts having
conversations with all the people there
and simultaneously there's a there's a
tell a retelling of the story of Jesus
is not along Biblical lines but with
parallels to what's going on in the
Soviet Union it's an interesting book
it's a well-written book it's a funny
book as I say I'm about halfway through
it I look forward to giving you my full
analysis of it when I finish the book
but Jordan has good taste in literature
so whatever Jordan recommends on
literature I'm I'm always the apt to
read okay time for a couple of things
that I hate
all right so let's begin with a
flashback so in in the 2012 election
cycle you will remember that the the
President of the United States at that
point said that the 1980s had called him
one of their foreign policy back because
Mitt Romney said Russia was a
geopolitical threat and the 1980s are
now calling to ask for their foreign
policy back okay and and then Vladimir
Putin today today announced that he had
developed invincible nuclear weapons
that can hit anywhere in the world and
cannot be stopped by missile defense
systems so well but well the presidents
of the United States Obama was sleeping
on Russia Russia not only interfered in
our election they also were building
these weapons now president Trump has
been a lot harsher on Russia he should
be even harsher than that but again
Democrats don't have a lot of ground to
stand on when they talk about the
Russian threat and then talk about how
terrible Trump is on Russia okay other
things that I hate so Chuck Schumer I
talked about the radicalism of the
Democrats on race Chuck Schumer
demonstrated at full scale yesterday so
he was talking on the floor of the
Senate about a judicial nominee that
President Trump had put forward and he
issues just a blatantly racist statement
and everybody overlooks it because it's
it's it's racism against white people
the nomination of Marvin Quattlebaum
speaks to the overall lack of diversity
and president Trump's elections for the
federal judiciary mr. Quattlebaum
replaces not one but two scuttled Obama
nominees who were African American
it's long past time that the judiciary
starts looking a lot more like the
America it represents having a diversity
of views and experience on the federal
bench is necessary for the equal
administration of justice I'll be voting
no on the quadrille down nomination okay
this is quite disgusting well he is what
he is saying of course is that if you
are white you shouldn't have a judicial
job if you are black then you should
have a judicial job he is judging people
specifically based on the color of their
skin and then suggesting just as justice
Sotomayor once did that if you are a
wise Latina woman you have a different
perspective on the law okay the whole
point of law is that it's supposed to be
a rule of law and not of men or women
you're not supposed to use your personal
experience to decide cases you're not
supposed to use your race to decide
cases you're supposed to use the words
of the law to decide cases unfortunately
Democrats don't care about that any
longer they've moved into this
intersectional cloud
from which they're having difficulty
escaping if they want Trump to win
reelection they should keep going with
exactly this kind of stuff but if they
also want the country to be ruined they
should continue to polarize this race
from race and suggest that skin color
should be the chief qualifier for being
a federal judge just insane okay we'll
be back here tomorrow and we'll have
mailbag for you i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018